[Music]
Hello friends and welcome to your
well-anticipated program 3abn today
Bible Q and A my name is idalia denzi
and it's a privilege for me to share
this hour of study with you all you know
you anticipate this program and so do I
I admire what the Lord is doing through
the family of 3abn who continually study
the word to be able to share the
knowledge with you you know I'm in
Proverbs 2 verse 1 and 2 says my child
listen to what I say and treasure my
commands tune your ears to wisdom and
concentrate on understanding cry out for
insight and ask for understanding so I
believe our friends at home are crying
out for that right that's why you are
sending in your questions and comments
well for the panel during this hour we
have Pastor Daniel morricone welcome
thank you so much for inviting me here
and thank you for your questions out
there too amen amen and we have Miss
Shelley Quinn with us oh it's a joy but
I do want to tell parents at home I will
be answering two sensitive questions
that have to do with scx and sexual
sense so they may be a little uh there
may be something you don't want your
younger children to have here so we can
send them out of the room
and of course we have my very own John
denzy John welcome to the program thank
you it's a blessing and a privilege to
be here and it's a real blessing to look
and dig into the holy scriptures because
God seems to open help us understand
more amen and since 1994 you have helped
me understand a lot of Bible questions
so I praise the Lord for that well folks
I hope you have your pens and something
to write on and of course have your
Bible with a with you too we are going
to once and for I would like to share
the contact information because right
now you're wondering man I forgot to
send in the question or the comment I
wanted to share with the panel well now
is your chance so Bible q a at
3abn.tv is the email on the screen or
for the radio listeners is the email
Bible q a at
3abn.tv and we have a way where you can
send a text and that text is
618-228-3975-618-228-3975 and of course
those social media people Instagram is
available through ABN underscore
official 3 a b n underscore official
some we anticipate your comments and
your questions but right now we want to
invite the Holy Spirit once again to be
with us to bless you anoint your ears
and your hearts so you can receive the
answers that the Lord has for us in
Jesus name let's pray father God we come
before your throne of grace we're so
thankful Lord that there is no question
too small or no question too big for you
everything you have covered in your word
now as we seek in the word and Bible
takes it perhaps we have read and
studied before but didn't really
register we ask your father to give us a
spirit of understanding to understand
the spiritual
points and answers we humble ourselves
before you Lord speak through us and be
with us and of course our families at
home thank you for blessing them with
this time of communing with you and
studying your word we dedicate this hour
to you may all glory and honor be given
you in Jesus name amen and amen amen
well our very first question we have for
Pastor Daniel moricone and I thank Ryan
for sending in this email now Pastor
Daniel why did God plant the tree of
knowledge of Good and Evil in the Garden
of Eden thank you Ryan for that question
that's I've never heard it quite
presented that way why did God plant I
love the plant things plant this tree of
knowledge of good evil in the garden but
of course we know that God had to give
Adam and Eve a choice in order to have
love you have to have Choice that's our
normal answer for that otherwise we
would be robots wouldn't we if we God
didn't give us the ability to choose
so I love what Dr Arthur Maxwell who
wrote the uncle Arthur's bedtime stories
he also wrote that 10 volume series of
the bed I mean the Bible story books and
in that chapter it's called The Test of
Love
where Eve takes the fruit and so forth
but I love this little quote in there it
says willing obedience
is a never failing test of love it's
good I just love that thought there that
I believe God put it into Dr Maxwell
let's go to Genesis chapter 2 and verses
16 and 17 where we see this tree that
you're talking about that Ryan that God
planted
and so I imagine God showing Adam all
the way all around the garden you know
all the beautiful things and Adam said
wow all these different trees and so
forth and then said the Lord God
commanded the man saying of every tree
of the garden thou mayest freely eat so
I don't know a thousand ten thousand
trees that hey you can eat any one of
these trees imagine wow fruit that we
probably don't have today but we
probably have mangoes and plums those
things but of the tree of the knowledge
of Good and Evil so he shows in this one
tree here
Thou shalt not eat of it
for in the day that thou eatest thereof
Thou shalt surely die that was pretty
ominous and God's telling him
ahead of time
that's what would happen to him so
there's this choice so now Adam has and
then I'm sure Eve too or else he told
Eve that he had that choice to stay away
from this tree so let's go to Ezekiel
Ezekiel chapter
28 and verse 15 because I believe that
when God created Adam
he was
you know totally perfect and selfless
because we see that here in where God
created Lucifer in Ezekiel 28 15 that
was perfect in thy ways from the day
that thou was created till iniquity was
found in thee so I believe that when God
created a being they were totally
selfless totally other centered thinking
about others and then Adam chooses to be
selfish right and take this fruit and
Eve also
and so as far as God creating this tree
or putting this ability for Adam to
choose
sin now already existed because that
started up in in heaven where Lucifer
and there was no tree in heaven right
that we're told so but Lucifer somehow
maybe eons that he was he had existed or
Millennia for sure
and then somehow
iniquity was found in him and we can't
explain that if to explain it would be
to excuse it there is no excuse for sin
so it's whatever however that came about
we don't know
but sin already existed so I look at
that God puts this tree in the garden
and maybe to speed things up where Adam
can say no I'll have nothing to do with
that tree and it won't take eons and
he'll make that decision to always
willingly obey God and not take from
that tree and not even get close to it
because I believe that's where the only
place that Lucifer could be or is now
Satan could be to tempt them he didn't
have free reign in the garden there but
just at the tree it's because it says
that he was cast to this earth when
Lucifer was cast down
thank you again Ryan amen thank you so
much Ryan Ryan represents a big
community of people that have the same
question you know I'm sure well now we
have a question for Shelley Glenn Miss
Shelley are you ready ready well Bernard
was ready and he sent that email and it
says like this with regard to the
Heavenly judgment can you explain the
following with scripture what is the
Judgment when is the judgment and when
will Judgment be handed down who is the
judge who will be judged and how will
the Judgment be conducted why the need
for judgment wow jelly may the Lord
bless you I shall answer all these
questions
it is a wonderful question Bernard I'm
going to answer but not in order I'll
answer each question why the need for
the just a judgment because Justice must
be served Justice requires judgment God
is a God of Justice mercy and Grace what
is the Judgment it is a legal
transaction that demands that our
Heavenly judge levies one of two
possible verdicts first either to
justify the person declaring them not
guilty that they are acquitted of their
sins or to condemn the accused person
declaring them guilty and worthy of
judgment who will be the judge the
person of Jesus Christ who died to pay
our penalty in John 5 22 he says the
father judges no one but has committed
all judgment to the son and I love
Daniel 7 22 that says judgment will be
in favor of the righteous if we belong
to the Lord we don't have to fear
judgment it's going to be in our favor
because our judge Jesus Christ is also
our Advocate who will be judged all
Second Corinthians 5 10 says we all must
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ that each one may receive the
things done in the body according to
what he has done whether good or bad
when is the Judgment how will it be
conducted I'm going to combine those two
there's two phases of judgment there is
a judgment that is happening right now
and their before Christ's second coming
and then there will be a judgment at the
end of the thousand years and I'll
explain that right now the Bible says
first Peter 4 17 the time has come for
judgment to begin at the house of God
and if it begins with us first what will
be the end of those who do not obey the
gospel of God the time has come Matthew
16 27 Jesus said the son of man will
come in the glory of his father with his
angels and he will reward each one
according to his work so Christ is
investigating the cases now to see who
accepted me as Savior they are the
Righteous I'm their Advocate I have a
reward for them but he will also have a
reward
determined before he returns for the
wicked revelation 22 12 he says behold
I'm coming quickly my reward is with me
to give to everyone according to his
work
so during the first resurrection the
righteous are raised judgment's been
made in their favor and then we spend a
thousand years in heaven and after that
there's the second Resurrection to
condemnation then the executive judgment
let's see how fast we can do this this
is at the end of times it is the great
white Throne judgment Revelation 20
verses 5-15 the rest of the Dead did not
live again until a thousand years were
finished now this is the first
resurrection blessed and holy is he who
has pardoned the first resurrection over
such the second death has no power let's
skip down to verse 11. he says then I
saw a great white throne and him who sat
on it from who who's faced the Earth and
Heaven fled away there was found no
place for them I saw the dead Great and
Small standing before God books were
open another book was open and they were
judged according to their works and if
their name was not found in the book of
life it says then death and Hades were
cast into the Lake of Fire
and anyone whose name is not written in
the book of life this is verse 15
revelation 2015.
was cast into the Lake of Fire to perish
well thank you so much Shelly thank you
and I know that you all have been
prayerfully studying this word in these
questions and here we are with another
question this time from New Zealand
through our Instagram so Linda thank you
so much so John Dempsey this question is
for you so be ready my question is about
Jesus's final moments on the cross when
he asks my God my God why hast Thou
forsaken me do you think Jesus was
shocked and taken by surprise that God
at that moment abandoned him to his
death would Jesus not have known this
would happen or is this Agony or is in
his Agony did it just become too much to
bear despite his Destiny being fulfilled
his words are heartbreaking and
gut-wrenching I can't fathom his mental
and physical Agony yet I am perplexed by
his seeming to not know that fulfillment
would mean God completely abandoning
everything including him
what up
deep question powerful
well I want to say Lynn I praise the
Lord because of the Expressions you've
made it makes me understand that you are
giving deep thought through the
sufferings of Jesus Christ for us and I
commend you for that and I encourage you
to continue to studying the Life of
Christ and his sufferings for us let's
go ahead and look into this I have to
say that there's no one scripture that
can answer your question I can only give
you that which has helped me to
understand these things because I have I
have done some digging in this
throughout many years
so the question is do you think Jesus
was shocked and taken by surprise you
know sometimes we express ourselves in
such a way even though we know something
because when the moment it happens it
seems like such a a an impacting thing
that we express ourselves saying
something that we already know but here
I would say to you that Jesus knew this
was going to happen we see in Psalm 22
uh the it's like we are taken behind the
scenes and we have expressions of Jesus
presented in Psalm 22 and Psalm 69 as
well and uh Psalm 22 verse 1 begins with
my God my God why has Thou forsaken me
so I would say to you that Jesus knew
but the moment it happens we have to
take into consideration that Jesus
had to suffer the way that Sinners
suffer in the time of the end and this
expression my God my God why has Thou
forsaken me helps us to understand uh
that
um the sinners in the time of the end
when they're suffering for their sins
and the great time of the executive
judgment
they are going to not they're not going
to have the uh the blessing of Mercy the
blessing of Grace of God's sustaining
strength they will have to bear the
guilt and the punishment for their sins
and this expression of Jesus helps us to
understand
that it's not going to be a walk in the
park having to face the punishment for
your sins Jesus expresses himself with
the same anguish that the Sinners will
feel when they uh have to face their
sins remember Jesus had taken the sins
of the world your sins my sins upon him
so uh I can I can only help you uh this
way also if you have ever lost a loved
one that moment of Separation when you
know I'm not going to be able to talk to
them again I'm not going to be able to
feel their Embrace this is a painful
experience and Jesus felt that however
in second Corinthians chapter 5 verse 21
we understand that it says that God was
in Christ
reconciling the world unto himself a
second Corinthians chapter five you can
see this in one of the ending verses so
this expression helps us to understand
the father was there but sin uh had to
create this distance between the father
and the son and that was a painful
experience this is as far as I can go
with the limited time I have
oh well that was wonderful thank you so
much but I wish we had more time but
thank you
um again Lynn from New Zealand for the
question now I want to remind you guys I
know that you're listening to these
questions in your at the edge of your
chair wanting to ask a question this is
your opportunity send us your email
bibleqa at 3abn.tv bible QA at 3abn.tv
or you can send us a text right we are
ready to receive it
618-228-3975-618-228-3975 and of course
the Instagram platform
3abn underscore official 3abn underscore
official well Pastor Daniel I'm going to
go back to you with another question you
ready yeah well Jenny sent in a text
Revelation 12 11 states and they
overcame him by the blood of the Lamb
how do we overcome Satan in our lives by
the blood of the lamb
and well Jenny thanks for that question
that's a good question amen
you know I look at that we overcome
Satan by God's love for us yes when we
look upon the cross and what God's
sacrificial love and giving himself to
save us that's what I see there and
let's just look at it in the Bible here
as far as to put it together here where
the blood stands for his love John
chapter 15 and verse 13 it says greater
love hath no man than this
that a man lay down his life for his
friends
so giving his life was the key they're
giving his life in the sacrificial love
and then going to Genesis chapter 9
verse 4 Genesis 9 4
it says that but flesh
with the life thereof which is the blood
thereof shall ye not eat so basically
saying that the life
you know greater love hath no man than
this that a man lay down his life for
his friend the blood represented the
life of that individual so there's where
you can connect that to and then also
Leviticus chapter 17
and verse 11
I cheated and put these little markers
in here I know that's my fingers are
kind of smooth there and uh 1711 for the
life of the flesh is in the blood so the
life of that individual
or the animal whatever it was was in the
blood and so when it says greater love
hath no man than this that a man lay
down his life so there's where the blood
comes in so when we're when it says
there that how do we overcome by the
blood of the Lamb by the life
and death of the Lamb of Jesus Christ so
looking unto Jesus you know if you're
tempted or whatever Satan's coming at
you look away from yourself look away
from the situation look unto Jesus yes
amen and his sacrifice for you
personally and then you will respond
accordingly you'll say oh man I don't
wanna
hurt him someone who sacrificed his very
existence that's right for us that's
what helps us to overcome by the blood
of the Lamb thank you again for the
question
and I know that sometimes we'd hate to
disappoint our loved ones even you know
what what greater thing it is with what
Jesus yeah it's all beautiful answer the
Lord has blessed so much isn't it a
delight to study the war together thank
you for that question will we continue
with the next question Miss Shelley are
you ready yes good because this one says
how does the bible define fornication is
it possible for a husband and wife to
commit fornication
parent alert
this is sensitive in adult material
there's two ways to commit fornication a
physical way and a spiritual way that
the Bible defines poor Nia in the Greek
is the word fornication and it is
various acts of sexual immorality sexual
intercourse with an unmarried person
harlotry prostitution
adultery adultery or casual
unrestrained sexual behavior First
Corinthians 6 9-10 says do you not know
that the unrighteous will not inherit
the kingdom of God do not be deceived
neither fornicators in the Greek that's
pornos where we get pornography nor
idolaters or adulterers or homosexuals
or sodomites nor thieves nor Covetous
nor drunkards nor revilers nor
extortioners
will inherit the kingdom of God there's
a spiritual component to this the
meaning of fornication is extended in
the Bible to include religious
unfaithfulness we see in the
second Angel of the Three Angels
messages that he speaks of the wine of
the wrath of babylon's fornication and
then in Revelation 19 3 many other
places as well but it talks about
Babylon the great religious Harlot who
corrupted the Earth with her fornication
so let's talk about husbands and wives
Hebrews 13 4 I'll read from the
Amplified let marriage be held in honor
and it's Amplified to esteemed worthy
precious of great price and especially
dear in all things and thus let the
marriage bed be undefiled keep dishonor
away from the marriage bed for God will
judge and punish the unchaste all who
are guilty of sexual vice and adultery
God created the beauty of marriage and
the act of sex within marriage for both
the pleasure of his people read The Song
of Solomon he meant for the intimacy
physical intimacy between a husband and
wife to be pleasurable also to produce
reproduction I mean to produce be
fruitful and multiply First Corinthians
7 2-5 instructs married couples not to
withhold sex from each other because
you're setting your spouse up to sin so
here's the quick answer yes married
couple can be guilty of fornication an
example watching pornography together
Jesus identified lust as adultery sodomy
a menajahtwa a threesome and technically
following the
fornication or the teachings of
Babylon but there's no need to be
ashamed of your nakedness there's no
need to be ashamed of intimate sexual
enjoyment in the marriage bed amen thank
you very much Sally that's one heavy
question huh but praise the Lord the
Bible has all the answers John Dempsey
coming to you right now we got the email
from Lauren and this is what she sent in
what would you say to people who said
that God through Paul told us in the
Bible that women should not teach and
she keep quiet
that's a very good question yeah and I'm
asking the question for Lauren so okay
we're listening well this is a very good
question and it's kind of a complex
scripture actually uh I go to you the
text you have in mind in first Timothy
Chapter 2 verses 11 through 13 it says
let a woman learn in Silence with all
submission and I do not permit a woman
to teach or to have authority over a man
but to be in silence
and so
um I just read up to verse 12. so we see
here this message by Paul and we have to
compare scripture with scripture when
we're looking at a a difficult subject
we also have to take into
um into the study Place time conditions
and we have to look at what kind of
conditions were here why was Paul saying
this we have to look at the context so
let's go ahead and consider here first
Corinthians chapter 11 4 and 5. notice
what it says every man praying or
prophesying having his head covered
dishonors his head but every woman who
prays or prophesies with her head
covered
uncovered dishonors her head for that is
one and the same as if her head was
shaved now he it is interesting here
because Paul is saying that every woman
who prays or prophesies so obviously the
woman cannot be in silence when she's
prophesying and so what does the bible
define as prophesying let's go to First
Corinthians chapter 14 verses
uh let's go ahead and read verse 1 and
then we'll jump to verse 3 to save time
pursue Love and Desire spiritual gifts
but specially that you may prophesy
verse 3 but he who prophesies speaks
edification exhortation and comfort to
Men He who speaks in a tongue edifies
himself but he who prophesies edifies
the church so we read before that a
woman can prophesy this means that she
has to speak in order to prophesy to be
able to edify the church so we have to
look at this second Timothy chapter two
as something different something is
happening here and Paul says that that
you have to uh let the woman be silent
and not to teach so what is going on
here
the issue there is usurping Authority
and this is why you have to look at this
in the aspect of what was going on and
notice the way Paul expressed himself I
do not permit a woman he doesn't say you
must know that it is written he is
saying I do not permit a woman something
was going on here in the church and
obviously apparently others were
permitting the women to usurp Authority
and then this was a male dominant
society and there was uh teaching taking
place in such a way that some people
somehow apparently especially the ladies
were listening to false teachings and
now they come into the church and are
presenting these false teachings and it
was apparently especially the women the
context and the wording of the Greek
there
uh you would do violence to say that
women cannot speak considering the fact
that it was Paul who say that women can
prophesy and so this is not this does
not mean that the woman cannot teach
it's a it was a local uh situation that
Paul was dealing with in this and that's
why you say you have to look at the
context you have to look at time and
conditions of what was taking place
so first Timothy chapter 2 verse 13 it
says for Adam was first formed then Eve
and Adam was not deceived but the woman
being deceived fell into transgression
see deception is brought in to help you
understand that there was some something
going on and apparently some of the
women were falling into some deceptions
and Paul didn't want that teaching to
take place so he says it's better for
them to stop and learn in silence
there's more to this in cultural aspects
but we have to stay here it's a great
topic and I praise God it's very clear
but I just I know that here it was first
Timothy 2 11-13 that was your your that
was that's the beginning from which the
question comes yes exactly not second
Timothy just wanted to clarify that yes
so I'm trying to be a good student just
like you at home so taking notes now um
we're gonna go to Daniel once again and
I want to thank Ernestine for the text
she sent in are you ready Pastor Daniel
I think so all righty and here it is is
there a difference between the Old and
New Testament
well thank you Ernestine that's a good
question is there a difference between
the old New Testament you can say well
that one the old was old and the new is
new in some ways though they're the same
old and new testament
if you look in II Peter
chapter 1 verses 21 it says for the this
prophecy the prophecy came in Old Time
not by the will of man
but holy men of God
spake
as they were moved by the Holy Ghost so
the Holy Ghost Came Upon an individual
and then they in this case wrote right
the Old Testament
anyway there was from the spirit of God
either old or new testament is that that
was the context that they were spoken or
the Holy Spirit came upon them they were
moved by the Holy Spirit and then they
in this case wrote the Old Testament and
the New Testament
and then in second Timothy chapter 3
verse 16 it says all scripture is given
by inspiration of God and is profitable
for Doctrine for reproof for correction
for instruction in righteousness so in
that Con in that sense the Old Testament
and the New Testament they're the same
in other words they're both written by
inspired individuals that wrote that and
then so you're asking is there a
difference well there's some differences
and one is that uh
like I said the old was written longer
ago but I like to think of it the Old
Testament was looking forward to the
Messiah to Jesus Christ coming so all of
those things in the Old Testament was
looking forward to Christ's second I
mean coming the first time and the
second time and then when the New
Testament authors wrote
and I think Paul was the very first ones
that we have his recordings
in the letters or the Epistles of his
and then I think after the destruction
of Jerusalem the others we have their
con
books like James and John the Revelator
and so forth he died on the Isle of
Patna so those are the most recent books
so that's one of the differences there
that looking forward to Christ's coming
and then after Jesus did come then they
were looking back so anyway that's my
answer thank you so much thank you so we
have the old and the New Testament and
all scripture is given by God amen amen
no doubt about that now Shelley ready
thank you this is a real parent alert
okay guys thank you so much for
reminding the parents at home these are
serious everyday people are facing these
situations so please let's listen up we
know that the law was nailed at the
cross
but not the Ten Commandments however we
still follow the law that homosexuality
bestiality and incest are wrong why do
we not follow all the laws in the Old
Testament John wants to know in Maryland
John
the Everlasting Covenant to your
question too
was
is presented throughout
the Bible Old and New Testament looking
forward looking back to the cross
but the old Covenant now let me double
check or make sure you understand what
the old Covenant was this was civil
social and ceremonial religious loss
that was given God spoke The Ten
Commandments but he gave to Moses civil
social and ceremonial laws Moses wrote
him in the book of the Covenant and you
find those terms Exodus 20 verse 22
through Exodus 23 verse 33. later at the
second giving of the law in Deuteronomy
he wrote God expanded these ceremonial
laws and various things he expanded them
and Moses wrote them in the book of the
law he put it on the side of the Ark and
the pocket that would be a witness
against them you find that in
Deuteronomy 31
24-26 so you're right that old Covenant
was done away with when Jesus came to
renew the Covenant and ratify it with
his own blood The Ten Commandments were
at the heart of the old and at the heart
of the new
what I want to say is the reason we
preach against homosexuality bestiality
incest and all of these things is
because God is Holy and a holy God is a
righteous God totally separated from sin
first John tells us all unrighteousness
is sin but God when he discarded the
Constitution for Israel he did not
discard the all of the laws that he had
for clean and unclean behaviors clean
means it's acceptable to God unclean
means it is not acceptable God to God
and God calls for Purity in his people
we've already seen that a holy God
created sex for the beauty of the
marriage relationship but Satan
perverted the sexuality and what he did
is he made it unclean impure that people
would satisfy the love step their
unrestrained flesh that were against the
Divine image and divine will of God so
Satan's out to seeking to destroy us
well before the old Covenant was
introduced God had holy principles for
purity of the sexual relationships
Genesis 18 and in chapters 18 and 19. he
judge Sodom and Gomorrah because of
their sexual sin we know in Genesis 39 9
even Joseph knew the the Patriarchs knew
the Ten Commandments and he told
Potiphar's wife I can't do this and sin
against them let me give you the
definition in Thayer's Bible dictionary
defines fornication pornia in the Greek
as one illicit sexual intercourse it
lists a adultery fornication
homosexuality lesbianism intercourse
with animals animals that's bestiality
and then B sexual intercourse with close
relatives from Leviticus 18. and then
their second definition is
metaphorically the world of Idols
fornication is mentioned 25 times in the
New Testament let me read Galatians 5
19-21 The Works of the flesh are evident
which are adultery foreign education
uncleanness lewdness idolatry sorcery
hatred contentions jealousies outbursts
of breath
selfish Ambitions dissensions heresies
envies murders drunkenness revelries and
the like then Paul says which I told you
beforehand
just as I've told you in the time past
those who practice such things will not
inherit the kingdom of God because the
old Covenant laws were done away with as
far as stoning for adultery or all of
the ceremonial laws they all pointed to
Jesus he fulfilled them we don't throw
the baby out with the bathwater
amen amen thank you Sally thank you
that's right we must move along to the
next question Canada is present they
sent in a text and this is from Lennox
and the question is John Dempsey this is
for you can you help me understand
Romans 7 25
especially the last part that says but
with the flesh the law of sin thank you
Linux John Dinsey you're on okay let's
read Romans chapter 7 verse 25 I thank
God through Jesus Christ Our Lord so
then with mine I myself serve the law of
God but with the flesh the law of sin
let's go ahead and back up in Romans
chapter 7 and begin in verse 18 to get a
little context on this for I know that
in me that is in my flesh nothing good
dwells
for to will is present with me but how
to perform what is good I do not find
this is the law uh of sin or the flesh
the law of sin uh notice now this is uh
in verse 22 Romans 7 22 4 I Delight in
the law of God according to the inward
man but I see another law in my members
warring against the law of my mind
and bringing me into captivity to the
love sandwiches in my members the flesh
oh Wretched Man that I am who will
deliver me from this body of death
that's the question posed at the end of
chapter seven remember there was there
were no chapter divisions uh in original
in the original manuscripts but Romans
chapter verse 1 has the answer to that
question who's going to deliver me from
this body of death this body that has
the the law of sin the the flesh that
wants to sin it says there is therefore
now no condemnation to those who are in
Christ Jesus who do not walk according
to the flesh
but according to the spirit
when you become a Christian you
understand there's a war between good
and evil and a more direct sense and you
notice that your flesh wants to sin your
flesh wants to drive you to do evil
because of uh your habits of the past
and the things you do in the past so
there's this war there's this conflict
inside but your mind if you have given
yourself to your mind you want to serve
the Lord so now I continue in verse 2
Romans 8 2 for the law of the spirit of
life in Christ Jesus has made me free
from the law of sin and death so when
you give yourself to the Lord Jesus
Christ you're no longer a Slave
to the Flesh and what the flesh wants to
do before Christ whatever the flesh
wanted to do your mind had already
consented before you would just go along
with it but now there's this war the
promptings of the Flesh and the devil
appeals to the flesh for you to send to
desire this to desire that
and so but through Christ we can become
Victorious and be free from the law of
sin and death verse 5 Romans 8 5 for
those who live according to the flesh
set their minds on the things of the
flesh so the mind and the flesh are on
those that are not Christians but those
who live according to the spirit
the things of the spirit now verse 6 for
to be carnally minded is death that is
obeying the dictates of the flesh but to
be spiritually minded is life and peace
because the carnal mind is enmity
against God for it is not subject to the
law of God nor indeed can be so then
those who are in the flesh cannot please
God
there's more in Galatians chapter 5 but
I have to respect the time thank you so
much John Dempsey well we got a next
question and this is addressed to Daniel
Pastor Daniel how will all I see Jesus
and his coming the Earth is spherical so
aren't we sent an Instagram message so
please answer all right why aren't we
thank you so much for that question
you're kind of like me I kind of you
know scientize scientific type things
I'm curious about and so forth this was
a good question and I've speculated the
answer to that over the years in my
thoughts I wonder how that's going to
happen every eye shall see him you know
in Revelation in fact let's go to that
scripture there Revelation chapter
one Revelation one and verse seven
behold he cometh with clouds and every
eye shall see him and they also which
pierced him and all kindreds of the
Earth shall wail because of him even so
amen so that's where your question comes
from
and while trying to figure that out you
know how can every eye see him probably
at the same time doesn't say that in
there but that's what we assume when
he's coming back
um
it says in Luke chapter 17 verse 24 it
will be like the lightning
that shineth even from the East unto the
West 24th chapter 17 verse 24 for the
lightning that lightness out of one part
of under Heaven shineth unto the other
part under heaven so shall also the son
of man be in his day so his coming is
going to basically you see lightning
like and we've moved here to Southern
Illinois and they've got some what would
you say Big Sky country I can see a
whole lot at the same time West Virginia
there was a lot of Hills so I couldn't
see a whole bunch at the same time
anyway I could see the lightning Wild
and the storm is way far away and so
that's what he's saying that we'll be
able to see that like the lightning so
I've speculated in my mind thinking
well how's that going to happen well
I used to do some my own mechanic work
and there was a thing called
timing in your car and there was a
flywheel and then it had a certain mark
on there and so you had this strobe
light and you would shine it at it and
it just pulsated the light and so when
you pulsated the light it made the Mark
it's like it was standing still
and yet you knew that it was spinning
really fast but it would make that
flywheel that Mark stand still with just
the way that light was so light is a
fascinating thing
and uh when he said it's going to be
like the lightning shining from the
Easterns of the West I think wow
something to do with light and how he
will do that just like you're watching
this program and I asked the producer
here and said how many frames per second
is this camera taking pictures and I
guess it's 60 frames per second but when
you're looking at it you can't see it
moving that fast so our eyes are a
marvelous creation of God and then light
is even maybe more marvelous but anyway
somehow it's going to happen and we're
just looking forward to that second
coming of cheese just be ready for that
second coming amen all right John
Dempsey I'm gonna go to you this is your
last question but we received a text
from Margaret from Indiana and this is
the question where in the Bible does it
say Satan can do Miracles John Dinsey
there are a few places in the Bible that
I look at but I want to say before we
look at those that the devil has some
limitations he can't do everything he
can't create anything but anything that
he does that we can consider a miracle
he doesn't do it for the benefit and
good of anybody he does set for
destroying corrupting or for deception
and that's what he does let's go ahead
and go to Revelation 13 and we'll see uh
hear some ability that the devil has for
that beginning in verse 11 it says then
I saw another Beast coming up out of the
earth and he had two horns like a lamb
and spoke like a dragon and he exercises
all the authority of the first beast in
his presence and causes the Earth and
those who dwell in it to worship the
first beast beast whose deadly wound was
healed notice he performs Great Signs so
that he even makes fire
come down from heaven on the earth in
the sight of men and he deceives those
who dwell on the Earth by those signs
which he was granted to do in the sight
of the Beast telling those who dwell on
the earth to make an image to the Beast
who was wounded By The Sword and lived
so you have here the whole Expressions
that fire seems like a miracle to us
coming down from heaven and we think
it's from God but is the devil doing
this so this is going to be a form of
deception that he will use that's what
the devil does he appears he can even
appear to make someone sick and then
take that sickness away through one of
his the devil servant and then you think
wow look look at this the devil is
healing people and so there's deception
on this and that's why you have the
Witchcraft and all these things and
which doctors and supposedly performing
Miracles but it's a sickness that the
Devil Himself has put on the people and
he takes these away he takes what he
already put there away Revelation 16
verse 13 and 14 and it says and I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs coming
out of the mouth of the dragon out of
the mouth of the Beast and out of the
mouth of the false prophets for they are
spirits of demons performing signs which
go out to the kings of the earth and of
the whole world to gather them to the
battle of the great day of God Almighty
so we have here again more deception
through signs and miracles that the
devil is doing so yes he has some
limited capability to do some Miracles
when God does a miracle it is a miracle
for the blessing of humanity you see
Jesus multiplying bread you see Jesus
giving sight to the blind you see Jesus
even raising the dead and so but again
the devil has some limited Miracles so
Miracles should not be a criteria to say
this is of God because the devil has
some limitation and he can do some
Miracles we need to be careful here amen
thank you for that biblical answer now
we're going to go to the last question
uh Shelley Israel from Ghana sent an
email and he would like for you to
answer what do I do when my question
life is going down
in less than two minutes
um it depends on the reason I wish I
could talk to you if you're burned out
some people in Ministry work so
tirelessly they continue on they get
burned out let me tell you if that's
your case rest in the Lord go take some
nature walks just talk with him like a
friend God will restore the desire to
study his word if it's apathy first
confess your condition first John 1 9
all who confess their sins he's faithful
and just to cleanse us forgive us and
cleanse us of all in righteousness pray
I'm going to give you several scriptures
Psalm 139 verses 23 and 24. search me o
God and show me if there's any wicked
way in me and Lead Me in the way
Everlasting Psalm 143 verse 8 caused me
to hear your loving kindness in the
morning and then verse tenses teach me
to do your Will Lead Me by your good
spirit Psalm 51 verse 10 created me a
clean heart oh God
practice the third step practice the
presence of God he is with you always
don't ignore him just talk to him like
you would be walking down the road with
your friend get into the word is the
fourth claim his promises if you're
having trouble start with Ephesians look
claim all the promises in the first
three chapters of Ephesians Romans 8
underline and claim all those promises
read first John and then finally believe
that God loves you he wants to restore
your relationship too quick Philippians
1 6 being confident of this that he who
began a good work and you will complete
it to the end first Thessalonians 5 23
and 24 that the God of all peace will
sanctify you completely and he says he
who calls you is faithful he will do it
amen glory to God what a blessing so the
important thing is to march on keep on
keeping on with Jesus right well we're
going to go to a break and we will be
right back
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
well folks we should have a word of
saying goodbye let's wrap it up Daniel
please
well I want to thank everybody for
sending their questions in otherwise we
wouldn't have this program thank you for
sending your questions in and it gives
us a time to uh it inspires us to study
deeper ourselves and so thank you so
much thank you now Shelley and I just
want to encourage all of us we need to
get into the word claim God's promises
speak them back to him pray them and
know who you are in Christ amen and John
Dempsey
I would like to say concerning the first
Timothy chapter 2 verse 12 the word Paul
says I do not allow a woman to teach but
to keep in silence it is clear that he
was addressing a current concern and
then that Timothy and defeat and the
Christians in Ephesus would understand
what he is talking about and we have to
see that in other places Paul says they
can prophesy and speak so we have to
understand that also quickly in Joe
chapter 2 it says and it shall come
verse 28 and it shall come to pass
afterward that I will pour out my spirit
on All Flesh your sons and your
daughters shall prophesy your old man
shall dream dreams and your young men
shall see Visions so we see here
evidence that again also in verse 29
that women can also prophesy praise God
Amen praise God for that oh it's a
delight to spend this hour with you all
thank you so much for making the program
your questions and comments are very
important may the Lord bless you and
continue to draw close to a message
study then thank you guys
[Music]
thank you
foreign